Stephen is with us in New York hi
Stephen welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
doing better than I deserve sir what's
up in your world all right so I'm
working on my debt snowball right now
and my wife has about a hundred and
twenty eight thousand dollars in student
loans that were working on say it right
now good so I'm hoping that I can get
this done in about thirty six months
I've been doing it for yes it's the
beginning of the year already mm-hmm and
the way the loans are there's sixty
three thousand dollars in one government
loan and that's the final one the other
sixty five thousand dollars is like six
smaller loans and the ranges of the
interest rates on them are like nine to
thirteen percent so I was wondering if
while I'm working on the snowballs it
would be a decent idea to go get like a
loan from a bank
at say like 6% interest and continue to
pay it off the way that I'm paying now
just you know just with a lower interest
rate so over the course of three years
accumulates less money well it's not
gonna be over the course of three years
it'll be over the course of a year and a
half and it's 3% spread you're talking
about max on sixty grand is eighteen
hundred bucks okay okay it'd be okay to
do I'm not sure you can get a six
percent loan can you have you checked
that out the big local background here
is like Citibank and they said that it
would be anywhere in the six percent
range fixed yeah it's not fixed it's not
going to help I mean it saves you $1,800
it doesn't solve $128,000 problem but
$1,800 if you send it to me I'll take it
but here's the thing okay here's the the
what I'm trying to point out and I want
to get through to you okay sometimes
those of us you are on task your game on
you are focused you're trying to do
everything you can to make this go as
fast as you can okay and oftentimes when
people get on in this situation they
feel like they
something big by moving the loan to a
lower interest rate and what I'm
pointing out to you is it's not that big
it's 1,800 bucks 1,800 out of 63,000 is
not does not fix your problem okay it's
it's you know it's not much so you
didn't do much but you helped it a
little but the big thing you did was you
now have a plan
you are now focused and you now are
intentional that's worth 128 thousand
not 1,800 okay and working extra and
tightening the budget and selling so
much stuff the kids think they're next
so that we make this get this done in 30
months instead of 36 months and all that
kind of stuff that's worth a lot more
it's worth tens of thousands of dollars
more than a cheaper interest rate
because you're not carrying this
interest very long I just don't want you
to feel like you did something big it's
okay to do it but it's not the it's not
the answer to the equation it's not the
key that's gone it's not the silver
bullet that's gonna unlock the door for
you does that make sense yeah you are
your secret sauce you are the reason
this is going to work because you have
had a wake-up call and you said I'm not
living like this anymore we're cleaning
this freaking mess up that is gold
that's the secret sauce so go go
consolidate it if you want okay but I
don't want any emotional relief from the
important thing which is you you be
in-game own you being pissed off is the
secret sauce that gets you out you got
this man you can do it proud of you